hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with the
morphe saga and we are in the second
game of the second match so the not so
serious one between other thunders and
paul charles morphy and it's uh six
games of kings gambit exclusively and as
both of the players are very very well
versed in the art of the kings gambit uh
the games should be very very exciting
but as the match progresses the games
will be uh getting more and more
exciting with the sixth game being uh
well just just a masterpiece
but that being said let's check out the
game in the previous game uh morphe one
uh in only 19 moves so let's see if
anderson can strike back he now has the
white pieces the king's gambit is the
opening uh let's see what happens so
anderson with the white pieces opens
with e4 we have e5 and f4 the king's
gambit of course is on the board uh
morphe accepted and now knight to f3 and
the g5 so nothing out of the ordinary
here as we already mentioned in the
previous video this is the uh to date
the the strongest reply from black
we have h4 by anderson and now morphy
accepts the challenge and plays g4 this
somewhat weakens the f4 pawn but black
will definitely have compensation with
knights the e5 now ready to pick up the
g4 pawn with the queen uh or the knight
but also depending on what black plays
even bishop to c4 might be an idea going
after this f7 even a sacrifice on f7 is
playable in some lines uh but like i
said all depends on what morphe plays
morphe replies with the strongest move
knight to f6 uh and now we have knight
characters on g4 and this knight
captures on g4 uh is um uh well uh
also to date the strongest reply
although you could play d4 here uh there
is a known game from 2001 alexia fedorov
played it against the vaseline vancouver
and um eventually defeated him in a very
interesting game
but d4 is is also played here even
though knight captures on g4 is
considered to be the strongest bishop
the c4 also playable uh bishop to c4 is
actually the most played move here
because this line is also still played
sometimes in you know even in 2021 but
okay anderson goes for the absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
knight captures on g4 and now uh there
is a really fun line with knight
captures on e4 and this is the strongest
move for black but we're gonna get to
that as this is uh
game six is all about this variation so
i don't want to spoil it for you uh we
have d5 by morphe and it is as of move 6
that this position has never been
reached again so obviously d5 maybe not
the most um
you know promising reply from black but
for those days it was uh quite quite
sufficient so knight captures on f6 uh
queen captures on f6 and now knight to
c3 developing and attacking on d5 and
morphy just plays queen to g6 a very
very tricky move that prevents white
from developing the light square bishop
here also uh is attacking the e4 pawn
twice so d captures uh well sorry about
that uh d captures an e4 that is is an
idea and you could play e captures on d5
here but uh i mean why would you do that
if you go for recaptures on d5 it's
queen g3 check king to e2 and now bishop
to g4 is checkmate so you can't play
that so instead after queen to g6 we
have queen to f3 anderson develops while
defending and now morphy says all right
i'm still not going to capture on e4
even though i should i'm i'm just going
to continue developing bishop to d6 uh
and now anderson should just you know
pause for for a moment and say all right
now i have to capture the point it's a
free pawn and when i capture there's
really not all that much you can do here
yes there are some ideas maybe the
bishop can come to g4
you know could be could be very
unpleasant but even if bishop to g4 we
can simply capture it queen captures on
g4 that's the problem queen captures
knight f6 check uh anderson wins the
queen so bishop to g4 would not be an
option for the moment uh you could play
something like just knight to c6
continue developing going for that those
d4 and the e5 squares for you know
attacking the queen but still we could
uh well pretty much play anything here
knight captures on f4 attacks the queen
we could also just spin the knight with
bishop to b5 and after queen f6 attacked
the knight here we can simply play
knight back to d5 and the position is
fine for anderson
but for some reason anderson again
trusts morphy and he doesn't go for the
pawn he plays bishop to d3 and okay now
you are threatening some e5 ideas with
an attack on the bishop and the queen
but not really morphy just plays bishop
to g4 queen to f2 and the now knight to
d7 he just continues development saying
e5 that's not going to help you all that
much if you play e5 yes there's an
attack on the queen and that the bishop
but i can play queen e6 pin your pawn
and you can't really capture anything
i'm just better here
so after this knight to d7 he captures
and d5 is played by anderson he finally
captures the pawn but the you know that
pawn could have been captured much more
elegantly uh and now okay the queen is
under attack but morphy just plays f5
and we have this very weird structure
here the bishop guards this pawn this
bishop guards this pawn and it really is
a problem for anderson to develop his
entire queen side first he has to move
the bishop then the spawn has to move
then the dark square bishop can be
developed and even then you can't really
castle queen side the bishop is guarding
that d1 square and do you really want to
castle king side here i mean it looks
doesn't look all that impressive so
bishop to e2 is one option if you want
to make room for this pawn push or
bishop to b5 this is what anderson
played and now he will try to push the
pawn maybe capture on f4 and get some
development in so a6 by morphe morphe
even encourages this character because
he doesn't want a castle he just wanna
wants to move the king connect the rooks
and then get the e8 square for for his
rooks to start an attack on anderson's
king so here uh bishop captures on d5
you could also try something else but
you know there really isn't all that
much to try here bishop captures and d7
is played king captures on d7 and now
you could castle and you know you would
survive for for some time but not very
long the rook is coming to g8 the other
rook is coming to e8 you're gonna push
f3 at some point and the the white king
will not be able to withstand all this
pressure and anderson still needs at
least three moves to develop his queen
side so after king captures on d7 we
have d3 now ready to develop this by
capturing an f4 for example but morphe
now starts the attack rook eight to e8
czech king to f1 and now rook to g8 and
uh all of morphe's forces are now fully
mobilized uh we broke the h2 adding
another defender to the g2 pawn here but
this is uh just asking for trouble all
the moves here are asking for trouble so
morphy plays f3 opens up a discovery
here uh towards the rook but now g3 okay
now you're guarding everything but there
will be a triple attack on this pawn
here so bishop to h5 now morphy is ready
to capture this uh pawn and now bishop
to g5 by anderson and now there really
isn't all that much for
uh for anderson to you know hold on to
it this bishop can be easily disposed of
by playing h6 this is exactly what
morphe plays and now anderson's position
is completely lost if you move the
bishop that's just it you you could try
bishop to f4 but that's not going to
help you we're just going to play
captures characters and rook to e2
and that's it even this is uh enough to
win the game if knight captures if
captures an e2 with check the bishop
nicely covers this pawn and once the
queen moves now we deliver queen to g1
check and that's it for example captures
captures uh king to d2 and now we're
gonna capture the a1 rook as well we're
up a piece uh we have a beautiful pass
pawn here on e2 uh of course completely
winning for morphe so anderson uh says
all right there's really nothing uh you
can do here let's play queen to a7 and
now i'm gonna try some sort of a counter
attack with knight a4 knight the b6
check maybe maybe it works out uh
because i'm really out of options here
and the morphe goes on a capture fast
fest on the king side h captures on g5
knight the a4 by anderson g captures on
h4 now comes queen captures on b7 uh
morphe ignores the queen side uh h
captures and g3 the these pawns are now
just monsters here and knight to b6 with
check morphy has the option of going
king to d8 or king to e7 king the a7
seems much safer
rook to e1 with check king to f7 and it
was in this position on move 24
that adolf anderson resigned in the game
and the game two also goes to morphe
where he uh well basically crushes
anderson uh with the black pieces in
this uh well a very enjoyable line of
the king's gambit so here you resign uh
there's really no attack happening here
the knight can't help out with the
attack the queen is useless here the
bishop here really does a nice job of
defending that c7 pawn and there's
nothing you can play here your rook is
hanging here if you play rook h4 it's
just a very quick trick made to g2 check
king f2 g1 queen rook captures and queen
captures will be checkmated the rook
covers the entire e file
and other than that there really isn't
uh anything else to play
uh so yeah like i said game two goes to
morphe a game three morphe will have the
white pieces and we will again have a
very very enjoyable line of the king's
gambit uh i'm expecting uh at least one
more video today from this match so stay
tuned uh as the games are pretty pretty
wild as you can see
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh while the uh you know the
uh photographers are preparing their
cameras uh these gentlemen are playing
fine chess uh i would like to thank uh
harry walk peter schugart and michael
keane online buy more and dimitar angelo
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the morphe saga until it ends uh thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day